here's a great
test of of writing something or anything
for any writer and it's it's a simple
one
so I have a little bit of a writing
challenge we can try and I'm hoping you
can um help me to make this
small bit of information better I'm
going to read it to you so my story is
about a young writer trying to break
through whatever breakthrough means
we'll call him Joe and he's a good guy
from a small town his parents were
hippie artists not a lot of money but
they supported his move to Los Angeles
and so while riding during the day and
very tired at night from these humbling
like grunt jobs Joe meets someone who
decides to take him under his wing and
it's a producer who says you know what I
like your work
and need some Polish but I'm going to
help you
and so the young writer Joe is just like
wow this is my dream come true I call my
parents and they say we're so proud of
you we always knew you'd succeed and
then after about a year reality sets in
for Joe
and Joe starts to see that he's being
used and sometimes abused and this
producer not only steals Joe's ideas but
he has Joe do a lot of his personal
Dirty Work like uh go spy on his tenants
go spy on his wife and also pick up his
dry cleaning
and then he he has him writes skating
reviews on a former Nemesis and he takes
those reviews and he uses them as in his
own because he used to be in a literary
world so he has Joe you know review some
of this other person's work and then
writes these these reviews and then he
publishes them as his own so
how could we clean this up this is about
like a story of a young writer who's
who's really hungry to be in the
business but he starts to see wait a
minute
I'm in a bad element right here I'm in a
bad way
for those of you who have worked in the
agency world this is the story of an
assistant
okay is that the log line that's the
long line no it is that's what it is
it's the story of an assistant and it's
the tame version oh okay wow all right
okay so mine's for all Auditors okay
great no it's true actually
um
um you know actually some you know you
know some insistence would be going oh
no it's much worse than that but
um
yeah no so what's the why what's the
purpose of this the purpose is
fines
goodness is taken advantage of
okay and and
my reflection on this is how can I clean
it up to tell the story better because
it's not just the idea but it's it's how
I'm telling it
well it's first of all you have to
shorten the shorten how you say it
um you have to you have to turn it into
a a concise bit of wording
um it has to become a log line or a
premise it has to be something that you
can issue briefly
that has a bit of a
snap to a bit of a hook something that
pulls you in
so um that is number one and so not to
say that it doesn't have it
but you have to you have to find it in
there you know a story
is um is sometimes like um like a block
of marble
and and and you're the Sculptor
and you have to you have to find the
form in the marble
what you have right now is marble
and you need to find the form
um
um Michelangelo used to say
um I don't know if you've ever been to
Italy but it's one of the most beautiful
things you've ever seen is the David
um but um Michelangelo used to say that
he would look at the um the block of
marble and he could see inside of it to
form
and and it's proven that he he did
because
um at the Academia where the um where
the um the David sits it's flanked on
both sides by um by his sculptures known
as the slaves
and the slaves were unfinished because
um I think it was towards the towards
the end of his life so
um Michelangelo basically
um chiseled straight in to the marble
towards the form
he didn't like like other other
sculptors Whittle all the way around the
marble Farm to get to the form he went
right to it so he'd be an arm sticking
out of the block there'd be a leg
partially in the block and the rest
would be all just raw marble so
that's what you got there is a bunch of
raw marble
um and you have to get to the form
that's inside and the Forum would be
your The Germ absolute germ of your
story you know
um the log line
okay so maybe the log line it's too long
but it could be a premise you know it
could be it's a long line it would just
be one sentence correct yeah technically
it's it's it's it's one sentence sure or
so it one or two sentences okay so then
Joe Young writer finds out that goodness
isn't always rewarded in entertainment
that's a little broad
um it's it's it's it um
Joe um
a young writer uh
is enthralled
by a mentor
in the Hollywood
industry
um
and moves
to Los Angeles to find
um success
and instead
becomes
um and it
is enslaved
um to a powerful man that's more along
the lines of of what you're looking for
I I tweak it a little bit more make it a
little a little better around there but
yeah that's what you'd be looking for
okay and and Joe who would he have as
sort of his supporting character so we
have this producer who's like the
Nemesis in some ways and then would he
have a roommate how can we make Joe his
dialogue with someone to actually tell
them about what's happening who would
Joe be bouncing ideas off of
in this story
I don't know you you're telling me the
story so who do you think Joe would be
bouncing the ideas off of it sounds like
you'd think there would be a roommate or
there could be a coffee girl oh sorry no
yeah there could be a coffee girl
um you know and
Joe could could be going through a lot
of things I mean the question is who is
Joe and who is Joe you know why is Joe
you know you know
um what what is what what what really
motivates Joe you know that all tells
you a lot of things as well
you know
um
you know that you don't you don't need
to have
um
attendant cliches
um to to make any kind of story
um in fact avoiding them
um informs who informs a very sort of
often often a unique way of subverting
them
um avoiding them
um it allows you to go down at
idiosyncratic Road
where you start to come up with some
really original stuff
you know
um so you you know sometimes you want to
get around that it's like what if what
what why is it why is it a coffee girl
you know what if he's gay that's true
coffee boys you know what if it said
yeah well it's a coffee coffee Point
um you know
um you know roommate roommate why is he
what if he lives you know
what if he lives with the with the with
the producer what if he you know lives
in the producers
um garage he makes him live in the
garage you know
um what if he sleeps in his car what if
he sleeps in his car
now now
something's visually now I'm starting to
think what if he sleeps in his car
you know
um lots of lots of young people come out
to places and you know they're they're
poor and they you know and and they have
to they have to sleep in their car
that's something I read about that's
something I hear about on NPR you know
um or the crummy weekly hotel yeah yeah
exactly exactly there's there's all
these other things you roads you can go
down
to to avoid those tropes
um and and it's good that you do because
you're going to get a more original
piece of work out of it
okay so I see yes so the cliche young
writer with the the proud parents back
home that maybe that that's that's
boring okay so then what if
we talked about what if the dad had a
gambling addiction and he gambled away
his college
tuition and so he wasn't able to get a
creative writing degree so he comes here
to LA and it's not a coffee girl what if
it's someone who does drag at night at a
club okay and basically tells them the
real deal and has no we'll just tell him
how it is and he he trusts that person
because they don't want anything from
him okay so then um and he basically
says you know the the let's say the drag
is Terry by night and then Terence by
day and then so so make it interesting
like just not the typical that's
beginning to be something I want to see
or read okay okay you see what I'm
saying right you're doing it you're
you're doing it right now you're going
down those off-roads and it's starting
to make me curious to the point where
like oh that's something I haven't seen
before I'm interested in seeing or
reading it
here's a here's a great
um test of of writing something or
anything for any writer and it's it's a
simple one it's like write what you want
to see you know write the thing that
you've never seen before that you're
like oh I really like to see someone
make a movie about that what what an
idea
you know what you know what a novel idea
I'll write the thing that's never been
done that I've always wanted to see done
so then I have to ask what happens to
Joe and how does he ultimately reconcile
with that job or leave it
and and then I have to plan out does he
quit does he get fired does something
happen to the producer does the producer
get arrested because maybe the producer
had
um a shady business on the side that no
one knew about
maybe he was involved in Auto uh he was
part of a ring of automobile scams so he
was in on it with doctors lawyers you
know workers comp all this stuff so he's
in on this and that's how he was really
making his money and that's how he's
funding the movies
and then he gets arrested and there's a
padlock on the house and the garage and
Joe's stuff is inside he's got to get it
out
so the sheriff has to come and let him
in
and then he goes back home
well yeah you could do that okay you
could do that as long as it's organic as
long as you feel that it's organic and
what you're telling me sounds fairly
organic
but um if it's not organic if anything
happens
the
does not seem organic to you as the
writer
um you should run from screaming you
know
in a run just run screaming from
anything that doesn't feel
um organic and natural to the characters
this is something we haven't talked
about is character is
that your character and what you've done
is you built up a character a character
profile more so than a long line or a
premise and
um and through that character profile
you have you've um
you have um used that as a template to
draw out what potential actions would
occur given that situation
so
um so now we since we know who Joe's
character is you know
um we we get a sense of how that will
play out character is a very very funny
thing it's very very funny
the reason why it's funny
is because it's prescient it's it's it's
a
um it's a
it's a it's a cute little tool because
it it
strings you along with like oh this is
the you know like you know it's not
going to go where you think it is but in
a way it always will
so it's a it's this little trick it's
like it's like it like gives you enough
bread crumbs to go okay it's gonna go
exactly where you think it is you know
but it you know it's gonna look like it
doesn't
you know
and that's what you do with character
um you um
you you you you set you set up
um the reader or the audience
um based upon the person's Behavior this
also works in tandem with um with
telling your story in the cut and
loading up your Exposition and I'm
between those cuts because if you're if
if if if if you show the behavior of
your character for example
and um you'll see this and stuff like
Lonergan does this did this in in
Manchester by the sea it's like uh if
you you know I go into a bar and
um and I get into a brawl
you know every time I'm going to go into
a bar in this movie you don't even have
to see me in the bar
you know
um you know there's going to be a brawl
happening you know
so so so
that
that's the sort of thing
um that you can do with character that
is um that is really really fun
um and is really really rich
um
um yeah yeah that's basically that
I feel like my character Joe is too much
he's too much of a good guy like he
needs some kind of Quirk or idiosyncrasy
he's too like he's surrounded by
interesting characters but why would he
stay in that situation I feel like he's
too flat so I feel like I don't know who
Joe is I guess
he's just like this guy that's
surrounded by all these interesting
people okay who is Joe then that's what
I'm trying to figure out so so Joe
maybe okay his dad had this gambling
addiction he found out that his college
education was gone so well if if his dad
had a gambling addiction you know well
he has to he has to have some you know
some serious resentments you know about
that you know and and those resentments
probably manifest themselves from some
kind of problem of his own
um um um addicts have a tendency to
Tibet to beget addicts
um and certainly have a tendency to
beget addicts and and the terms of
Storytelling so
um you know that's a very easy one to
Target you can there's a ton of things
you can choose from it's other
psychological issues
um it could be it could be alcohol he
could be a cutter he could it could be
numerous things that you can use as uh
as tools you know right so Joe's not
just going to come out of the womb
perfect then from well you no he
wouldn't no he wouldn't come out of that
perfect because he's you know he's gonna
he's gonna be resentful of his dad you
know
um there there's you know there there
was a that dysfunction in this family is
going to be manifesting him even if it
is in even if it appears to be um
positive on the surface
um the that's always fun to do is to do
that little ironic thing with a
character where they um where the
um the negative aspect of that character
looks like it's positive at first but
it's actually when taken to an extreme
it's negative
would you mind giving me an example
Harrison Ford mosquito Coast
so it looks as a positive where he he's
a he's a good protective father but
instead he takes his his family to some
like remote location and like puts them
through hell
you know you there's there's
you can take things that are good and
you can make them
at their at an extreme bad
um at any time
okay so then maybe the movie opens with
he and his dad
um betting on football games and it's a
father-son bonding and you think wow
they have such a great relationship but
then you realize
that some serious issues are happening
he's owed money you know he has a bookie
that he owes money to and it's just it's
getting out of control but you don't see
that at first you just see this father
and son watching these games and you
think well that's really neat like they
have this close relationship yeah yeah
and and and and and and and and and and
and and and to a certain extent his
father can be a good father sure he
could be a good father but still be you
know this kind of loser you know
um there's tons of there's tons of
humans like that sure male or female
yeah yeah and so then I'm trying to
think though how Joe would be scarred
from that but
um
yeah yeah that I think that's where my
trouble lies with this character is Joe
is too perfect surrounded by some people
that they're not damaged maybe they're
just very interesting people and I've
got to make Joe
not so one-dimensional
I think that's my problem is that
everyone else is more lively than the
protagonist
yeah yeah or
you can do some crazy stuff let's hear
it well I mean like
um what I mean by that is is that
um there there's there's other areas
that you can go
um you can go you can go down the line
like you're suggesting or you can start
to get meta with your character
um you can
um you can you can trade off your
character with other characters in your
story you can you can make it appear to
be about Joe and then it actually starts
to turn to be about somebody else in the
story
um sometimes sometimes like the Coen
brothers will give equal parity to some
characters and you'll go like I thought
the story was about this guy and why is
it now about this guy and and and and
and and and and and and that's because
they're Adept at pulling that off you
know not ever I wouldn't suggest that a
new writer should should go out there
out the gate and try things like that
but
you can do stuff like that
um it it's you know the this don't you
know you should if you are if you are
writing and you're having fun and you're
in the zone so to speak
um you shouldn't you shouldn't be
limiting yourself
um on ways that you can tell the story
if the story wants to go there if it's
organic
um if the story doesn't want to go there
then you don't go there
hmm that's interesting
yeah I think I really need to rework
this character because it's not I'm not
clear on who he is I feel like I'm clear
on some of the people around him
and
he's not
damaged enough or fully formed see well
well you know what would you do in this
case so once again have you written a
screenplay before I have not no okay so
so how would you approach writing this
well I think I would try to outline it
so okay I would maybe do
um I know what's been popular is 24 I
think it was Adam Skelter talked about
he had a teacher that did the 24 plot
points or whatever 24 24 beats or
whatever
um which is the same as 12 but it's 12
okay all right it's just doubled yeah
but and so I'm gonna have the opening
um of maybe on the couch and so all
right we got the you know the popcorn
and all the stuff for the game or
whatever maybe maybe they're drinking
together
um Joe's over 21
um and uh it looks like they have this
great moment so I'm gonna I'm gonna go
from there from that number one opening
and start
um and then we're gonna see some stuff
unravel at home maybe some yelling with
the mom
um and then
you know the the hard discussion about
I'm sorry
um
you're not going to be able to get to
yeah but after you're done with all that
um you're you know and you get all those
those points in there
um you're gonna you're gonna write it
right
sure in in screenplay format yeah okay
so I may have screenwriting software
okay okay and then when you're when
you're done writing it you're going to
have hopefully something that's going to
be around like 80 to 120 pages right
okay okay
then then once you have that 80 to a one
120 Pages the whole world changes
and I don't mean just like I don't mean
like you know necessarily the world of
script I mean your world
um because you are going to come and
look at that script with new eyes
and um and and and the new eyes that you
bring to that script is going to um is
is going to have a profound effect on on
your protagonist and that main character
none of every anything that you um that
you come out with as a as an idea for
like an outline
um or a thought like that is going to is
going to magically crystallize into the
exact thing that you want
um what happens at least to me
um
quite often is that I'll start off with
a vision of what I'm going for
and then along the way that vision
changes and then towards the end it
really starts to really dovetail towards
the vision the original Vision but not
how I've expected never how I expect it
it dovetails towards the original Vision
but never down the road I expected to
get
that's when I know that it's organic
because
I will sit there and I'll go like you
know what
this is what I want to do you this is
what new writers have to learn how to do
um to make the Sophie's choice between
what you want to do and what's best to
do for your script
you know you might sit there and go like
you know what I really want to do this
because this is how I thought of it
no no that's not best to do for your
script what's best to do for your script
is this over here
because it's where your characters want
to go it's where your story wants to go
so you need to go in that direction
and you keep going into that direction
until it all falls into place
that's the way it works it doesn't work
any other way you know
um
and I would defy any any
um successful writer to um to
um
to say to say anything otherwise about
that experience
um
it happens like that it's like you're
like wow it all worked out in the end
you know
um but
never to a t but you have going on up
here
at the beginning
okay so I won't really know what I'm
working with until I take those 24
points and then I put them in screenplay
format write anything from 80 to 110
Pages or thereabouts and then maybe wait
on it a week or so
and then I really am working with the
beginning of the marble
that's right okay that's right
um um
um
Ernest Hemingway
had a famous phrase
um
and um I'm gonna I'm going to I'm going
to use the
the
sanitary version
is that
every first draft is crap okay okay okay
or poop right yeah keep it yeah every
first draft is poop okay good okay
and that that is a perennial it'll never
go away
for time and memoriam for everybody you
know every first draft is poop even if
you think you're like no this is great
no it's poop
You Know You're Gonna Come Back
and you're gonna you're gonna look at it
and it's going to come together the
other thing about that is
and this is this is this is something
every writer should know really at the
end of the day
um with with my familiarity with the
process and with all the writers that
I've known on so many levels
um successful otherwise and everything
there's no such thing as a finished
screenplay
that Medium never is complete
you may think it's complete
it's never complete
a screenplay is finished
when the director calls action
that's when it's finished
there's no there's no designated finish
to a screenplay and if a writer ever
takes that for granted
that's they're they're not doing their
job
writers should always be ready to come
up to bat and say I can make it better
or I can I can do this I can like
communicate this better I can do if
you're if you at the if you're like on
set
and the uh and and the director is um is
shooting the film and and he says you
know what
tomorrow I'm about to shoot these like
five pages
I I I'm not feeling it and the
producer's not feeling it
can you go back and rewrite them you're
going to go back and rewrite them you're
not going to say I'm done
[Laughter]
if it's finished it's you know David
Fincher it's finished
it's finished David Fincher
I mean yeah that's all you that's all
you get out of me you're not going to do
that
you're gonna you're gonna go you're
gonna go home at night and you're gonna
rewrite those five pages for David
Fincher and you're gonna bring them the
next day and that's how it's going to go
down so yeah
there's no such thing as a finished
screenplay okay
and so is it is it when the director
calls cut or is it when they calls
action or she calls action because when
it's when um he or she calls it action
action yeah okay it's like um because
they're shooting it
um
I mean
for hopefully they don't rewrite your
your movie in post
but you know sometimes they do